the guys it's lovely to see here at the
Sundance Film Fest with your film cold
in July now it's one of those films
that's very interesting because it's
kind of a crazy concept he's got a lot
of gear changed in that feels that some
of the kind of things that appealed to
you when you took it on absolutely I
mean the this jumping-off point for me
was reading the script and I was amazed
at how many genres seemed to be honored
many so many tones were in the big rich
stew of it and how many surprising I
mean it's immediately surprising and
then unexpected things happen and you
sort of settle in with that and then
something else happens that you know
discombobulates you yet again so yeah I
mean I think that's a big part of why
it's a really special film Jim said it
well I mean he said that he's was kind
of bored with movies that kept you get
to page 20 and you think okay then I
know where this movie's gonna go with
this film you have no idea what it's
gonna go and it keeps actually unfolding
just like like an onion it just keeps
spilling into you know the core of what
the movie is all about and you start by
the vitamins from the beginning and all
the way to the end understand you know
it's truly about like fathers and sons
and family and you know you don't expect
it to turn out like that quite so but it
really does bring you back home to that
that principle so you mentioned the
films directed the Vanessa Jim Mickle
and of course he's worked with one of
the other actors in the movie Nick to
meet see very many times hasn't won lots
of his films very successfully how is it
coming into that kind of relationship
where they've got that shorthand
together as new actors to their process
in a way
what's great working with a director and
his actor and co-writer they have a
cohesive vision a singular sense of
purpose in terms of why they want to
tell the story and have you know
unpacked it and repacked it and
reassembled it so much that they they
know it so intimately it's it's it's
there's a real sense of safety that goes
along with being on a set helmed by a
director for whom the the material is so
personal you're safe to be unsafe you
know
that you aren't otherwise I also felt it
was just fun because as as well as Nick
being on the the crew that whole crew
was from we are what we are Jim's last
film that premiered here and everybody
has you know it's like a machine a
well-oiled machine so I felt very
comfortable coming into it that
everybody was family and so he didn't
have to worry about you know any sort of
glitches I felt like a fella
it gave me as an actor the freedom to
explore and just enjoy myself and it was
also like summer camp because we're all
in one hotel except for you Michael I
don't know why you we're so far away
from us really consulted or I didn't
yeah anyway I'm finally what can we look
forward to next invite you guys I'm
doing a play on Broadway called the
realistic Joneses that will start
rehearsing in February and I imagine
take me through the spring into the
early summer it's been talk of a spinoff
from Dexter and they said they'd love
you to be involved is that something you
like to do what would you like to see
happen I can't really wrap my mind
around that possibility I think I need
to put some more space between me and
Anna it's been it's been really nice to
mix it up and do different things I I
would never say never to anything trying
to get Don Johnson who's in the movie to
to deuce play Sonny Crocket again I
think there could be like a Sonny
Crockett Dexter Morgan Private
Investigators outside the box kind of
firm but we'll see I'm doing a
three-episode arc on this new Annie show
called those who kill and I play one of
the killers anyway and then also I just
I'm doing a small indie movie about a
father who's growing older and doesn't
know where to turn next in terms of
dealing with death in general and I play
his daughter and who's really uptight
and doesn't understand him in least but
by the end really does so it's a
beautiful kind of daughter father father
daughter story actually so
you